[Music]
here we go again Sony have revealed the
free games for PS Plus subscribers for
the month of May 2020 you can get your
hands on these games from the first
Tuesday of the month which is May the
5th if you're ready and if you press
subscribe let's do this
I completely understand if you do not
like this month's offerings at all but
please remember I do not choose these
games the first game is cities skylines
a game which is here to let you build
monitor and manage your own city from
basic first towns up to a hulking great
metropolis this game is so deep you'll
be managing road placements services and
even taxation riveting stuff hey I know
this is an ultra niche gaming genre but
hopefully it fits somebody out there and
maybe while we're mostly in lockdown
this could be a genre you've never tried
before if you like budgets and grid
system train electronics wow this is a
really tough sell Game two is just as
hard-hitting it's farming simulator I
honestly have no idea why these games
are chosen together but if you've ever
wanted to try life as a farmer and plant
grow and cultivate crops this is the
game for you my friend
I gotta admit the last time I played a
farming simulator I decided to draw a
massive
rocket in the cornfield happy days I'm
sorry if it seems like I've had the life
sucked out to me these were not the
games I was prepared for and I know
they're not very exciting but hopefully
somebody does love them I hope that's
you are you gonna try any I buy them
totally not there's enough free-to-play
games to get me through the next month
I'm Adam from Playstation grenade and
that was PS plus for May let's try again
next month
[Music]